[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the
what do we call it the pods moving and
storage studios i'm just getting used to
saying this yeah yeah
and uh the paid work debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships ken
coleman is carrying me through the
opener today and the rest of the show is
my co-host he is the ramsey personality
over all career things including the ken
coleman show and the number one
bestselling book paycheck to purpose
we're here to help you with your life
your money
your career the phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the answer lane is on the line to
start off this hour lane is in kansas
city hi elaine how are you
hey dave ken thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
yeah so i just had a quick question so i
currently have
uh 14 300 left on the car
i could get that paid off in february
but i don't know if i should
pay that off first or just save up
for our first child that's going to come
in april
uh when you're having a baby on the way
we tell folks to push pause
on their baby steps push pause on their
debt snowball and pile up cash
okay so you
i would not pay off your car i would
just pile up cash as big a pile as you
can have okay and just how do you stack
cash like you were trying to pay off the
debt but just put it in your own account
never touch it for anything unless
there's an emergency
and then when mom and baby come home
from the hospital and everybody's
healthy and everybody's safe you push
play again which means that day you're
gonna pay off your car
okay okay you won't have lost anything
except a little bit of interest on your
car between now and the time baby comes
and right now we're focusing on more
important things than car debt and
that's baby
okay understand that
i bet you do how exciting
yeah it's very exciting your first one
yes all right
fun good for you man how old are you
guys
uh i'm 24 and she's 26. cool
yeah so
you're gonna have several thousand
dollars towards your baby step three
above your fourteen thousand dollars
for the car debt
uh because the car will evolve just by
paying the payments you will have
reduced the principal some
and you're gonna save money and you said
february was your target date and
april's a baby so you would have already
saved you know several thousand beyond
you should have 16 17 000 bucks saved
and when you pay off the car you got a
good start towards your baby step three
then following me
yeah we currently have 7 400 saved up in
savings right now oh so you're not
really working the baby steps
i mean we we are
no you weren't either baby step one's a
thousand dollars everything above that
goes towards the car but now the baby's
coming it's okay we're gonna push pause
anyway and we're gonna pile up the cash
okay
all right
thanks for the call bro open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
so ken uh you might get called out on
this show
even if you're a nice young guy with
your first baby on the way i might still
smack you around a little bit yeah if
you act like you're working the baby
steps and you're not that's right
there's a reason why you've got seven of
them and they actually go in order and
they make a lot of sense
same thing with the paycheck to purpose
that's right you know you got to get
clear and you know i'm kind of working
this but i'm not clear
you're not working it yet that's so true
you know there's a process here that's
proven and they're gonna go with that
process yeah you gotta you gotta walk a
plan you know no matter where you are in
your life maybe it's physical fitness
maybe it's uh some health stuff
relationship stuff going on when you
have a gap between where you are and
where you want to be
there is always going to be steps
to build that bridge if you will and you
walk across that bridge to where you
want to be and you got to follow it you
absolutely have to follow it yeah and
we're hardcore about it and the reason
is it works well ish is a wish every
time you issue it right you slow down
your progress well can you lower the
probability of actually hitting it
that's right so let's take his scenario
let's say baby wasn't on the way he's
new to us whatever he is you know and
he's going okay i'm gonna pay it off in
february and he's juiced that savings
baby step one is a thousand dollars he's
juiced it to 7 400 and and what he could
have done instead of kind of holding
that back worrying about something
to play it out the way that you've
taught it for decades
then he's so much further along in
paying off that car and paid off by
halloween that's right then that goes
towards how quickly he gets his
emergency fund set and then that goes
into 15
and so everything fast forwards when you
actually walk our plan out yeah yeah so
you know
just just be ready that um if you say i
don't understand them that's okay we're
gonna pick on you for that
but um yeah so so
do this stuff the way guys we've had 10
million people go through financial
peace university
this is not our first ride on this
cabbage truck
so we want to help you
we we want you to do but but you know we
the shortest
right way from where you are to wealth
is what we've laid out and we're going
to do that with you every single time
freddie is in
iowa or i'm sorry louisiana hey freddie
how are you
very well sir thank you how are you
better than i deserve what's up
um sir i'm fixing to retire i'm 70 years
old my wife is 62
uh we
have a home we have a very small
mortgage on it
um we have uh
five steps it's appeared and beam
construction
and she's laid up right now with a broke
foot and she'll be laid up till january
and every time i go up and down them
steps like i was telling the gentleman i
want to go it's a land mine and it's
gonna bite me one day
uh we're we're wanting to build a new
home uh
on slab uh
have it
not necessarily handicapped accessible
but more friendly toward toward our age
okay uh i'm wondering
the main thing i'm wondering about right
now is should we go ahead and do this in
the next few months begin
or should we wait a year or
so well i don't want to get laid up in
cripples where i can't yeah i'm saying i
don't want you to either um
and if i thought that was the only
option i you know we would talk about it
but obviously it's not um i mean you
made it up and down those steps a bunch
of times you probably got a few more in
you but the uh but yeah let's go ahead
and have a plan
um i'm actually drawing a home right now
i'm thinking i'm probably going to build
in the spring
and i'm maybe
if everything has calmed down a little
bit
but uh but the you know as you know the
real estate world has been out of
control oh you're crazy
and so you don't want to you don't want
to be building a house in the middle of
crazy and some builders act like they're
doing you a favor but oh yes we will
consider building your home uh no you
got this backward bud so i'm the one
giving you money
so uh you know this you know got to kind
of get on the right side of that
equation and i don't know in your area
if you're there
you could certainly interview a few
builders and look at some plans and say
okay this is what we want to do and see
if you get a the right attitude and b if
they can give you reasonable pricing
based on
construction materials availability
supply and demand cost right now
most of that has evened out after the
the uh pandemic economic suppression
when we shut down the world to flatten
the curve you remember that that was
weird
and um
now we're trying to catch up on all the
production that was not done in the
factories and it caused inflation
and so now that there's not as much
scarcity and there's a little bit more
abundance of the items some of the
prices are starting to stabilize the
components of a home for instance lumber
prices that kind of stuff so that's what
we're facing right now
check it out right now but um
personally i'm thinking it's going to be
spring before it's going to get a little
bit more normal this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today if you're listening to this show
there's a good chance you already know
success in life doesn't just happen
it takes daily
goal setting as a matter of fact it
takes goal setting that are broken down
into daily bites we call that motivation
right it's the kick in the pants to stay
focused if you uh want to get better
with your money if you want to have a
deeper spiritual life build amazing
relationships in 2023
you need to be intentional with every
day of your goal setting so we have
created the new 2023 ramsey goal planner
the ramsey goal planner shows you how to
set and reach your goals and the best
part is we completely redesigned it ken
and uh wow it's uh pretty cool delony
cam uh dr jaloni george george campbell
rachel cruz have written uh the ends of
the months it's um beautiful it's
gorgeous look at this much thinner and a
little larger format people this is what
our customers were asking for we've been
doing these for several years christy
wright started it back when she was here
and uh now it has moved on to the ramsey
gold planner and it is uh actually this
is kind of like my wife uses this month
at a glance the cheap ones from these
things as well and uh you can get the
cheap one from walgreens or you can get
the good one from us but uh in addition
to that of course it's got uh
a um yeah what do you call it a
devotional each month to kick off your
month with and the first month is by
rachel from romans 8 39 and then it goes
through a day by day goal setting this
is designed exactly like you guys out
there have requested this is like our
sixth year of uh producing these and
every year they sell out
early uh they are technically not
available today we will start shipping
them in october but today they go on
sale in pre-sale and they're 49.99 so
this is a nice
product this is not a el cheapo if you
want el cheapo run over walgreens and
get the month at a glance that's the
actual brand i'll give him an
endorsement okay and um and i can give
you sharon ramsey's endorsement on that
she has like uh has them back for 30
years or so
but uh she will be getting this one this
year oh i'm going to upgrade it does she
know is this the same oh it's a secret
okay and she doesn't listen to me on the
air so it's still a secret it's
absolutely locked in
i can say a lot of stuff and get away
with it except for her friends will tell
her if i say something bad so i have to
only say good things learned that about
30 uh see i've been on the air for 30
years so i think i learned it 29 years
and 12 months ago just recently yeah
so but anyway yeah uh this this thing's
incredible it's beautiful let me feel
that this thing's got hardcore oh no see
you've got a real serious weight to it
this is also the obviously what they
call it on instagram if you're like if
you're one of those people they have an
opening party so you can i don't know
something like that like a what an
unboxing unboxing thank you kelly in the
booth
because
not my uh i'm not the focus group on the
unboxing bunch i'll just tell you boxes
are things that are very they're in the
way of the thing i'm trying to get to
um and so but the rest of you enjoy the
process of thinking you gave yourself a
gift or something but we're going to
help you with that because this has got
a great box so there you go you unboxing
people will like it too who knew i i
didn't before today's show i didn't know
that existed
all right obviously i even knew sort of
about it that's impressive 49.99 starts
to ship out in october you can get them
starting today the new ramsey goal
planner ramsay solutions dot com slash
planner or just jump over in the store
at ramsey solutions and we'll help you
get one all kidding aside it's an
incredible product and here's the thing
we do know this
in every area of your life people who
set goals win
my friend zig ziglar used to say if you
aim at nothing you'll hit it every time
yeah and those that don't set goals
there's a high correlation between
people that set goals break them down
into daily habits and the ones that
actually accomplish something whether
they're looking for a new job in career
whether they're trying to get out of
debt whatever it is
yeah i mean listen if you want to grow
in any of your life you're going to have
to come up with a destination and then
what does it take to get there those
steps to walk up that mountain and this
is going to help you it's a wonderful
product we call the desired future you
know what has to be true that's not true
today
for you to be that wait for you to have
that spiritual walk for you to be in
that kind of condition
and so on that's the process
so uh our question today comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and the new promos
that run every month you'll save even
more always use the magic word the promo
code ramsey blinds.com today's question
comes from robert in kansas i'm an
appraiser for a civil engineering firm
that takes state contracts for road
projects a competing firm asked me to
work as an independent contractor on
projects my employer is not working on i
currently earn five thousand dollars a
month and this would bring in an extra
two to three thousand dollars a month i
have not signed it non-compete and have
not been told i can't moonlight the
chances of my current workplace finding
out about this are low would you
recommend taking on the extra work while
i tackle baby step two based on what i
see here i absolutely recommend that you
do it but i but i wouldn't have this
this mindset of where i'm trying to keep
it a secret um you know if they find out
about it uh you know you just need to be
fully uh prepared to have a conversation
with your leader every leader is
different on these type of things but
based on the the information i have here
in the question it doesn't look like
this is looking like a gray area you
never want to walk in a gray area with
your leader or with the company that you
work for
so if it's black and white and it's
straightforward non-compete it's not
even
anything that looks any way uh fishy and
i gotta use common sense on this um then
i'm fine with you going to make the
extra money but that's why you're doing
it and the fact that you're asking about
it at all makes me wonder
if you kind of have some kind of a touch
some kind of little check and i think
there might be a little fear here there
may be some reason you need to you need
to tell your employer
if that's the case but if there's i
don't know what you're afraid of because
you're out you're not you're not
stealing their customers you're not
competing in any way you're not
prohibited from doing outside work so
there shouldn't be an issue that's right
um you know for instance what comes to
mind for me is we've got uh like 300
people that work here that are
developers software engineers right
and uh if they're not we don't have that
requirement that they can't work outside
of here sometimes some of them take on
contract stuff on the side i'm sure uh
and we don't we don't require them to
disclose that uh we don't tell them they
can't do that
we would frown on it and it is in their
employment contract that uh our
employment agreement that they're not
doing something in comp with our
competitor but uh uh but other than that
you know if they're doing you know
taking on a project for whoever that
doesn't get anything to do with the
spaces we're in then i i as their
employer would have zero issue with it
that's correct and so if i had an issue
with it it would be in my agreement
that's correct that's right so they
really wouldn't your employer really
shouldn't have any
gripe because they've never addressed it
but
the only thing that bothers me is you're
even asking the question which makes me
think something is weird but it's okay
it's okay but yeah nothing you talk i'm
with you what you put down in the email
dude yeah yeah i would go do it yeah
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five mitch is in
allentown hi mitch welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave hi kent thank you for uh taking
my call sure
i have a question about uh the ssi
survivor benefits social security
survivor benefits um
well i lost my wife six years ago from
cancer and prior to her passing
my children i had two children they
started getting to receive these checks
and i didn't know anything about
what i'm supposed to do with this so
i've been just storing that money away
and saving it for them so when they get
older i can use it for college to cash
flow college and
whatnot but now i received a letter in
the mail because my son is going to be a
senior and saying that
any unused or unsaved money or anything
that you've collected interest on they
want to return
that's i'm like
shocked
so i don't know
i'm confused that doesn't exist that
sounds like a scam
i mean it's detailed as a letter about
what it is but i'm just looking at the
part if you save any money from you know
your children we want you know you
return any unused money
and you know unless there's a no that's
not that's not a thing
okay because
ssi does not ask for a return of minor
benefits if the parents saved it for the
use of the minor
it's just not they don't do that okay
because
either you're misunderstanding the
letter or the letter you got it's not
really from them and it's a scam
be careful okay be careful yeah it's
just not a thing you did nothing wrong
legally and certainly not morally um
i probably would have done something a
little different but that's not the end
of the world you still are a great dad
you took care of business
you know when in doubt i saved the money
that's never a bad default button
right right that's that was my thought
and options to save until they really
needed for something and i just did the
beans and rice until we can uh you know
so i mean if it comes up what i would
just say if they actually did try to
enforce that i would just say i spent
every dime of it on their care and
feeding the money i put in savings was
mine
okay because it's just got a different
pocket in it it was all into your
account first
and then you moved it so the exact same
i just choose the same to save the same
amount of my money and you don't get
access to my money i spent this on their
care and feeding which is what it's for
so shut up but i don't think it's gonna
come up
that's the point it doesn't really
matter this is the ramsey chef
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important
you've got to know where you stand so
you make your next move the right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author talking with you
about
your career your extra job your larger
shovel is my co-host today the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage david
and laura are here hey guys how are you
hey dave
welcome welcome good to have you where
do you guys live
we are in southern pines north carolina
okay great good to have you guys
and how much debt have you paid off
253. 253 000
love it and how long did this take 38
months all right and your range of
income during that time it was about 1
30 to 2 10. okay great what do y'all do
for a living i'm an army dentist
and i work as a digital operations
manager for healthcare system great very
cool well great income 253 000 over
basically three years
excellent what kind of debt was that it
was basically all student loans we had a
little bit on a car but that was a
significant amount of student loans
about
100 or 237 000 on student loans
seriously whoa
yeah and you jumped on this okay so what
happened 36 three years ago a little
over three years ago it got you started
on this whole ramsay thing yeah so um
really coming towards the end of dental
school i started obviously freaking out
about our debt we both had out of state
tuition for undergrad and then i had a
portion of dental school with the
military i didn't pick up for a
scholarship so um i started from the
military pickup uh my my following three
years so i just paid the first year
dental school okay um
so yeah i started freaking out uh
started trolling the internet figuring
out how we're gonna get through this
mountain of debt um came across ramsey
network started binge watching the shows
and um
felt committed instantly for me it made
sense it was a it was a foolproof plan
um so the next step was basically going
to laura and trying to figure out how i
was going to get her on board so
convincing how to you know buy financial
peace university and then sit down and
watch the videos the dvds yeah
how did he do that oh well i mean buying
them was easy i was watching there's a
lot of dvds and i was honestly not
freaked out by our debt the way dave was
like it felt very normal all of our
friends had not as much but they all had
student debt and so i felt like oh we
don't have credit cards like we're good
um
but then we had our daughter and she had
a lot of um unforeseen medical stuff and
she spent three months in the nicu and
was diagnosed with a
genetic syndrome that just kind of
changed everything and for me i think i
needed like a bigger why like the debt
itself didn't scare me the way it did
for dave i was like oh we can afford it
but just kind of having that bigger
purpose is it that
kind of got me award-heated and honestly
the more he was like coming at me i was
like no no
i don't like being told what to do
sometimes
it's hard yeah coming at them usually
ain't the way that doesn't work
that's good okay so you finally sit down
now that you've got this huge why
and you start watching the dvds what
clicked what made you think um laura
that this is going to work
well what really happened is the first
year of those three years we were davish
we were kind of doing it my way where i
was like oh we'll budge a little bit but
i still i just wasn't committed and then
we had watched them and then we kind of
watched them again especially like the
the first couple
and then it just started working like
when we followed your plans that's when
we like we paid off 40 the first year so
the second two years we paid off over
two hundred thousand dollars and i was
like okay once it starts working you
can't deny it you're like all right
game on yeah
i've got a question uh for both of you
david how did you
handle the relationship part when you
were davish and then lord i want your
perspective because you weren't
completely on board from the beginning
then you were kind of dave-ish seems
like you kind of just were patient or
what was that relationship tension like
until we got all in all on the same page
i mean i think it was just that it was
relationship tension right i mean i was
i took over the budgeting you know i was
using an app and using excel spreadsheet
and basically just
making the money disappear you know each
paycheck i was basically just dumping it
at student loans i mean like i said
those second two years i was you know
over a thousand dollars a month was
going out the door to sallie mae so
i guess i was just kind of plowing ahead
and then i think the the momentum kind
of caught laura when i was sending these
these you know these numbers of
snapshots of the debt going down i think
that's when it really started to be like
okay it's real for her he was very
patient
he was very patient with me
okay
very very cool well done well done you
guys very well done all right now when
people hear you paid off this kind of
debt 253 000 in 38 months
um that's that's herculean i mean you
guys are heroes when then they say how
did you do that what do you tell them
the key is
i i for me it personally i just don't
think there's like a really like a
secret sauce to me like you guys
basically have like the perfect cookie
recipe and it's just you just have to
follow the recipe i think that's easier
said than done but for someone like
myself if you give me the ingredients i
can just follow the recipe so um i guess
laura could maybe answer that question
about yeah i mean dave doesn't buy
anyways like he's not a spender spending
is that's not a thing that's fun to him
so for him to like commit to the process
i don't think it was outside of his
comfort zone anyways
um and so if you are someone like me who
gets joy out of shopping and going on
trips and doing all these things like
you have to
almost like tune out the things around
you and also retrain your brain like
just because you have a certain income
doesn't mean you like deserve nice
things yet like you might need to suffer
a little bit to get there but if you do
suffer i mean once we're on the other
side of it it's
it's totally worth it and in retrospect
you're like dang that was really fast
like it doesn't feel that long yeah now
that we're done yeah if you do the rip
the band-aid off if you don't do the ish
yeah the ish we'd still be paying so
yeah maybe another five years yeah and
that was the best thing is like when we
did it you know during the pandemic we
fortunately did it at a good time
because we were locked inside yeah we
had a daughter that was kind of
immunocompromised so we stayed inside
and we just basically hammered out that
and you know student loans being on
pause like we were just making
insane principal payments yeah yeah
so how's baby doing she's great she's
wonderful so she's with us
her name is what addison addison yes
little addison okay you may not get her
back from janelle yeah looks like
chanel's found her a buddy she might be
sleeping for the screen we'll see
that's all right we can have it we can
have it good stuff you guys very very
well done very well done very proud of
you we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you next chapter in
your story for sure how ordinary people
build extraordinary wealth how you can
do if you can pay off 250 000 in 38
months i think you're going to be
millionaires
and also a copy of financial peace
university the new videos and you can
give this away it's a one-year
membership to that you can give it away
or you can uh go through it again
yourself of course and uh we've also got
the
total money makeover for you to give
away to someone no addison's with us
she's wide awake and ready to go ready
for the debt-free scream good stuff all
right david and laura and addison from
north carolina 253 000 paid off in 38
months making 130 to 210 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're done
yeah
well done you guys
well done
well that's that thing you and i were
talking about back at the beginning of
the hour the uh the
this idea of okay here's a proven plan
submit to it and i i kind of get it
because i'm always the rebel i always
question everything on the one hand but
on the other hand i don't pay
a personal trainer 150 bucks or whatever
and uh then go you know i don't like
that part of your advice
and i got a keg and he's got an eight
pack you know
and so i i don't you know i can't you
can't really argue with his results
versus my results so i've gotta say if
i'm gonna do this or you know if i've
got a pga golf instructor right who who
can play
20 strokes better than me i'm like you
know i think i like my stroke that's
right i really i don't you know i
appreciate your input but i'm sort of
going to swing like that i'm really not
you know that part's not comfortable for
me oh well yeah you know and so it's
just this thing of submitting
to uh someone that you're paying
who has proven
that they're performing at a level
you're not yeah it's right it just it
just removes all frustration this is a
hard journey let's make no mistake about
this if you're new to the program
walking the baby steps while the plan is
simple it's hard enough as it is and i
can think back dave in the early days
when my boys were in the legos trying to
build those elaborate legos you know
what follow the instructions or else
you're in for a world of frustration you
know just follow the instructions i
don't even want to talk about little
bolt a4 and bolt a6 to put some of these
stupid buttons and all the toys
follow the instructions just shoot it
works you end up doing it three times
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
matthews in washington dc hi matthew how
are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve sir how can we help
hi so i just had uh i guess good
questions about retirement investing
i don't know much about investing i
recently started a new job and
and trying to set all of that up
so i've heard that you should consider
your current salary or tax bracket now
versus what you expect to be in
retirement and then base choices off of
that
but i guess my specific questions are is
one
what is your advice on 401k versus raw
or versus having some combination
and two what are your thoughts on a good
investment option or options once i
choose the type of account
um cool a little bit of back story about
me i'm i'm doing
i currently set it up just out of just
blind guessing i'm currently doing six
percent in traditional and three percent
in a roth i make about 120.
so yeah
okay well the first thing we would tell
folks to do matthew is to make sure
you're out of debt and have an emergency
fund in place before you start investing
are you out of debt okay
i have about 32 in student loans okay i
would temporarily stop your 401k
until you get that paid off and i'll pay
that off with great intensity you need
to do that very very fast
because i don't want you missing this
for 1k for very long
very quickly beans and rice rice and
beans no life until you get this paid
off
really fast okay like your hair is on
fire okay then once that's done i want
you to have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses
and uh in your case that's gonna be like
20 grand and this is a fund you don't
touch for anything except for
big time emergencies
this is not a i decided i want to go to
the bahamas for the weekend fund
this is a emergence that's not an
emergency by the way uh emergency is a
negative thing it's an unexpected event
okay
so um right
then once you've got that then we
suggest you put in 15
of your household income
into retirement
and that's what we call baby step four
the first three are getting a thousand
dollars and getting out of debt and
having an emergency fund is one two and
three then baby step four is 15 of your
income into retirement that co is where
we come to answering your original
question okay
but that's going to be more than you're
putting in now by the way
so
here's the way the math will work out
for you how old are you
27 okay 100 of the time here's how the
math will work out best for you
regardless of tax brackets and there's a
whole bunch of different reasons because
a lot of these goobs that write these
articles do not consider how people
actually live when they get to
retirement and we do
because we work with people that are in
retirement that have a million dollars
in their 401k we work with them all the
time so we actually see what they do
here's what they do they don't use any
of it
the income off of it is what they live
off of if you've got a million dollars
it produces a hundred thousand dollars a
year
okay
right and so you know
in reality if you follow this stuff you
don't end up actually trying to figure
out oh roth oh traditional oh back and
forth here's how it works a hundred
percent of the time
number one get all the match you can get
because a hundred percent return on your
money which is a match
you can't screw that up with taxes or a
bad investment
okay
so always take a hundred percent return
on your money before you start a hundred
percent so to get all the match you can
get then the second thing you do is all
the roth you can get because roth is tax
free at 27 years old when you get to
retirement 97
of the money that is in your retirement
plan will be money that is growth
you will only have put in about three to
four percent and the rest of it will be
growth
the growth is either taxable or it's not
taxable
it's either roth or it's traditional
okay
and so you want it to be roth if you got
a million dollars taxes is 250 000 no
taxes saves you 250 000. pretty simple
equation
i like that okay so roth everything roth
until you run out you can't do any more
then if you still hadn't gotten to 15
and the only other option available to
you which is not true in your case is is
non-roth or traditional then i would do
it i would do some traditional so in
your case
you're going to take all the match
you're going to switch your 401k to all
roth and then you're going to do an
individual roth as well
to get you to 15 of your income because
you're probably you might get there all
at work i don't know no it's gonna be
borderline though uh but yeah if you can
get it all in the 401k that's just fine
too then the last thing you ask about is
what to put the money in here's what
mine is in here's what ken coleman's is
in sitting next to me and here's what
we've recommended for 30 years and it
continues to work
i spread my mutual fund investing
in my retirement across four types
evenly 25 percent each ready
growth
growth in income
aggressive growth
and international
and i look for the fund in the selection
that i have in your 401k that has the
longest best track record
in each of those categories
warning ahead of time the
underperforming category of the four is
the international
it's not done as well
okay but i i still want some overseas
i don't want 100 bet on the american
economy i'm trying to diversify across
types of funds and types of stocks and
over the long haul
that'll play out every single
time i got a letter on my desk that came
in this morning from a guy who started
19 years ago he's got three million
dollars and all he's done is those four
funds
starting from nothing
all he's done is those four funds
and
the weird thing was the letter is now
he's spooked and he's wondering if he
should keep doing it
that's just hilarious but yeah no i'm 62
i got millions of dollars in my
retirement and it is all in those four
funds my i don't ask people i don't tell
people do stuff different than i do it
so matthew your new listener we're
honored to have you hang on we're going
to give you a copy of total money
makeover
and
send it to you and it's going to give
you the details on the baby steps and
the details on what we just talked about
i want to encourage you matthew really
quickly because you heard what dave said
you got this high right now you're on
the air you're going to get off the
phone and when dave said to pause 401k
you said yes you nodded your head we
could feel it but you're going to
probably have some friends and family
members try to talk you out of that to
do both at the same time and the reason
that dave and we at ramsey solutions say
pause is we want you to get all that
momentum of having one singular goal and
that is to get rid of that debt then
you're going to catch up you're not
going to fall behind at all but i just
wanted to warn him because you know you
hear that it's like going to a
conference and a speaker gets you all
fired up and then you go back to the
real world and other people who don't
prescribe to this kind of thinking and
living or people who don't understand
why we teach we teach will tend to be
naysayers and you got to guard yourself
blinders on here blinders on real life
kicks in i mean you come home from the
marriage counsel uh marriage conference
and he leaves his underwear on the floor
i mean it's just real life kicks in
right i mean that's just how it works
and so you're that's a good warning and
um
and here's the other thing uh matthew
one of the things we have around here is
if your broke friends are making fun of
your financial plan means you're right
on track
so you just you know if broke people are
arguing with you then you you're doing
the right thing
so uh your most powerful wealth building
tool is your income and as long as sally
mae has her own spare bedroom at your
house as long as navient lives in the
basement
uh you got a problem they're sucking
your paycheck away and so you have to
smack them in the nose and get rid of
them as fast as you can it's vital that
you get control of your most powerful
wealth building tool because saving 15
of 120 000 is no picnic but it can be
done if you don't have any payments yeah
and so when you prescribe rice and beans
beans and rice that is that is a
struggle but it is designed to
streamline
you getting out of this process and now
it's all just compound interest in
investing and doing those things you
talked about and so that's that's the
thing you got to understand uh there's a
reason why you say you have no life it's
to get done as fast as possible get
through the storm as quickly as possible
you know what you can do if you've got
three or four million dollars in no debt
a lot more than you could do in your
program you know i mean you got these
choices you got options in and that's
the idea that's what we're wanting to
take you to we want you to be a baby
steps millionaire
so um and that's the next step after you
get through this stuff so it's it is
hard it is living like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else no discipline seems pleasant at
the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
that one's the bible that wasn't me this
is the ramsey chef
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they actually love
and create real amazing relationships
ken coleman ramsey personality speaking
of doing work you love is here as my
co-host today we'll be answering
questions about work you love and about
your money and about your life and uh
your career your
job how you get a bigger shovel all that
is included today
for free the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the call is free some say the advice is
worth exactly what you pay for it
vanessa starts off this hour in los
angeles hi vanessa how are you
hi i'm doing fine how are you guys
better than we deserve what's up in your
world
thank you so much for taking my call so
um i have about three months of
expensive space so i'm in the middle of
baby step number three and i'm looking
to move out and i'm not sure if i should
be leaning towards renting an apartment
or working towards purchasing something
move out of your parents house
um well i rent a studio from my
grandparents house which is really small
and i don't have a kitchen so yeah i'm
looking to upgrade
okay and what do you make a year
65 000
okay
all right and you live in los angeles
proper or what
yes i live in los angeles by downtown
l.a okay all right
well as you know you're in a pretty
expensive real estate market agreed
yes i agree and um
so 65 000 doesn't go that far
you're not exactly broke you have a good
job but um but it's it's an expensive
world to try to think about rent or
buying either one in your situation
so you are did you say you're out of
debt
i am out of debt yes and i work from
home so i am like
flexible i can move out of la i don't
mind like leaving l.a i just you know
don't know if it's the best thing to do
what's the comparison between what
you're paying for the studio with your
grandparents versus something else
that's not it was exorbitant or
luxurious but
an apartment with a kitchen what's that
going to cost you in la
probably like another thousand dollars a
month compared to what i'm paying now
what do you pay now
i pay only like 350.
now if you can get that for 13.50 you
got a deal
that would be a deal yeah um
yeah okay
um obviously your family is in l.a
how old are you
i'm 25. what do you do for a living
i work in fraud prevention for an
e-commerce business okay good for you
okay thank you um
okay so
here's the thing if you don't see your
income coming up
fairly quickly
you're going to struggle to own real
estate in l.a soon
it's gonna take a while
okay so i'm tempted
as a short-term adventure to move you to
a less expensive market as an adventure
not a permanent solution maybe maybe it
is a permanent solution
but pick a city you've always wanted to
live in and let's try something new
you're 25 there's not much holding you
except family ties and let's go
somewhere where 65 000 goes a lot
further
yes i agree and then you could get a lot
of a little bit nicer rental situation
while you save like crazy to buy a
property um and then talk about as your
income comes up now if you tell me that
in
three years you're going to be making
165 k then i'll shut up
but if you're going to be making 65 and
then 75 and then 85 you're going to be
there a while in la
yeah
so i'm not trying to talk you out of
this but it's just no matter what your
career path is because this is a math
thing and you don't get a pass on math
just because you're in california
and that's the question i have is what's
driving your future decision right now i
know it can change tomorrow but right
now is it
live in a more affordable place and keep
doing the kind of work i'm doing or is
there a much higher professional goal
that you're you're dreaming about
um i think right now it's just moving
into a more affordable place i just got
this job right so i was making 40k just
three months ago and i just received a
new job so now i'm like good um
yeah i'm just ready to
move out and basically start my adult
life finally yeah well i agree with dave
i would be patient and uh get into this
new professional role let's move to a
much cheaper area the fact that you're
working we say after christmas we start
talking about
moving to a different city
yeah that's what i was aiming towards
yeah let's just stay in the studio till
then
okay that's what i would do because my
birthday my birthday is in march so i
was hoping like by march yeah
yeah and then you can move to what if
you were just going to pick a city today
just for fun for us to talk about what
city would you pick
well probably somewhere in riverside
county because i also have family out
there but i don't know if it's like a
lot of a difference in like rent no not
much
yeah that's not that's not really a
different city i mean that's just
that's moving from one problem to
another there but i mean if you went to
northern california uh into some of
those areas you know there's more
reasonable stuff going on there or you
just go to an adjacent state
you know
yeah
we start talking about um tucson or
something like that i'm just making it
up okay but so you just start saying
okay by march i'm gonna be here
if i'm not seeing a huge increase in my
pay
boom over boom over boom
okay
because you you in order to prosper in a
very very expensive market you're gonna
have to get north of six figures pretty
quick
okay
it's just a shovel thing i mean you got
a hole you're in and a shovel you to dig
with and that's what we're discussing
here so the good news is you're in an
area a field that you've chosen to go
into that if you'll get continue to
study take classes uh get the
certifications in that area security
internet security stuff is just quite
hot and you could go way up real fast
yeah i think there's three things that i
would give to her and anybody's looking
to kind of level up and get that
paycheck bigger
learn something new every day within the
field i mean every day you're learning
something maybe it's uh through a course
or maybe it's just somebody who's more
experienced than you do something with
that knowledge and make sure you're
connecting all of the time real
relationships and real conversations
with people in the field
because by learning doing connecting
you're going to automatically have
opportunities that come to you because
you're very attractive people could see
that your leadership sees that about you
and before you know it you're moving up
and you're making six figures and see
opportunities you never saw before
you might consider moving to the city
where this company is and working in the
office
because that way you can be actually
around the human beings that are doing
this it's um one of the problems with
work from home is out of sight out of
mind on promotions
uh they forget you're there
they're not even sure you are there
that's correct that is correct whether
the data is showing that uh as people
are trying to wrestle with whether or
not i go back to work or not the data
shows that uh there's a much greater
chance of getting promoted because
you're actually getting noticed yeah so
here's a weird thing promotions also
happen on relationships yes and that's
not a good old boy network it's just i
can trust you if i've actually seen your
eyes
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five guys we really value
the input from people who watch and
listen to this show and we want to know
what's important to you we want the
right content for you the right
questions the right challenges and right
now you can share your thoughts with us
by answering a few questions in our new
survey that we just launched the ramsey
show is doing a survey
you can check out check it out at
ramseysolutions.com
survey it's free you can only take a
minute or two to take it it's a favor to
us if you take it you're in a drawing
for a 500 visa gift card that's up for
grabs to thank you for your time
someone that takes it will win that nice
look there ramsay solutions.com survey
and you can answer the survey on your
phone just takes a few minutes but we
want to know what you're thinking about
what we're doing and again just visit
ramseysolutions.com
survey
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five ken we need
to talk about this uh employment
situation you're the expert on this
and um
i'm an expert on my opinion so we got a
really good opportunity here to talk
about this
but um
uh
there is some weird
economic data
that the media is not parsing through
and it is telling a dif that is telling
a different story of reality than the
politicians on either side
want you to believe
okay so side one is
uh that
you know we're at the best
job market in the history of the world
there's a shortage of workers
we can't get enough workers i can't fill
the jobs that we have available at
ramsey
okay which is true by the way probably
got a hundred positions we could fill
today
roughly we can't get so there's for you
know there's at arguably full employment
anybody that really wants to work in
this current economy is working
is able to work is working
uh from an economic perspective
um and so
the current administration would say
look at us look at this great economy
although we know we're in a recession
we know that the fed thinks we're in a
horrible
inflationary situation so they're going
to slam
interest rates up and and what they said
so that they can cause some pain that's
correct that's exactly what the [ __ ] at
the fed actually said we want to cause
some pain we want some more unemployment
and we want things to slow down
well thank you very much
you
aristocracy piece of trash
oh my god yeah the first thing we want
to do is not let the little people
prosper if we're in the fed
so i already trashed on him last week so
i'll just hold that for now yeah hold
that thought but anyway so we've got
this side that the economy is in such
good shape that it's inflating
and the marketplace is full and
yet
and there's a shortage of workers
and yet
we find people looking for work every
day there seems to be a shortage of
quote good jobs so what we're really
finding when you dug into the data you
were showing me this earlier
is that it's not um it's not as easy as
saying jobs that's correct it's what
jobs that's right there are more options
the way to look at it is there's more
options available now to people than
previously existed that that are
attracted to them so example where we
see less jobs give you one really
dumpster fire situation we have 300 000
less teachers now than we did prior to
the pandemic 300 000 less teachers how
many less police we've got that's
correct you've seen a lot of
municipalities with jobs so local
government state government jobs aren't
as attractive as they used to be and and
there's a reason for this this is upward
mobility and i think a lot of people are
like well it was always safe but it's
always been pretty stagnant so there's
more opportunities for people you're
seeing people move into delivery jobs
you're seeing people moving to
warehouses
the environment of those jobs the
culture
what it feels like to be a cop today or
feels like to be a teacher today is way
different than five years ago there's no
question about that we actually saw this
recently just about a month or so ago
you can look it up for yourself uh the
fraternal order of police had their
meeting in washington dc the national
chairman of the sheriff's they came out
and said we're losing good people and
they're moving into a different sector
of the society do the same type of
protecting work so a lot of private
security things of that nature because
they don't want to be treated this way
they don't want to feel unsafe so what's
happening is we've just seen a big
reshuffling of the chairs and so what
happens is when you hear things like
well there's a job gap well that that's
a function of there are one and a half
jobs
available for every person that's
unemployed in the united states you see
a lot of people choose retirement not
come back out so we've got this big gap
and so when you see a gap like that what
you see is companies are competing
everything from a kid making 16 an hour
at target that's real
20. yeah but i'm talking about a 16 year
old kid i got a friend of mine who just
got that job and so what happens is that
you see inflationary pressures from
wages
so now the fed's going well we've got a
good inflation under control and what
they're trying to do to get inflation
under control is drive off unemployment
the august job numbers were out we're at
3.7
unemployment we were 3.6 in july so
they're actively trying to drive
unemployment up hoping that that will
cool type of unemployment that goes up
is going to be those century entry
levels that's correct so it's not going
to actually solve the inflationary price
it's not going to solve the nursing
shortage or a cop shortage it's not
going to solve uh you know
dev2s
developers no software engineers private
sector is going to drive that nothing's
going to nothing's going to change any
of that that they're doing that's right
it's only picking on the little guy
that's why i was talking about the the
arrogance of the aristocracy because
they are looking at a number as a jobs
number holistically rather than saying
all right let's parse this and go okay
uh by the way uber eats is way up well
what does that really mean
well i'll tell you what that actually
means when uber eats goes up it your
prices go up so your 18 pizza is now 22
your combo meal
so that's what's really what i mean what
what's that guy doing what would he what
would he have been doing with his life
if he wasn't doing a breach well he's
probably in another hourly wage position
and so he's gone it's a side hustle
that's exactly right are they counting
the side hustles as
as full employment no they do not so
part-time jobs
are in a separate category in the jobs
report so the unemployment is it's
really where someone's choosing to be
unemployed meaning so they're not
working a full-time job part-time really
doesn't count doesn't weigh into that
okay so if you're a professional
uh a b or c position
that makes um 80 to 150.
okay um
there is a uh
you've got your choice right now
right now you do right now you do if
jerome powell and the fed has their way
it could really squeeze that we could
see and he's predicting
fourth quarter layoffs first quarter of
2023 layoffs 150 000 is not at the front
line of the layoffs
uh not at the front line but you're also
seeing like larger companies will
because they get concerned about the
economy you could see those people get
laid off and now you're gonna have
another rush for that position so
facebook and google and um one other one
i was trying to remember who was in the
article came out and said i believe it's
apple if they don't have an increase in
productivity they basically threaten
their team
that if you don't have an increase in
productivity that um we're uh gonna have
to do layoffs yes and yet the vast
majority of their people are working
from home and then turn around tim cook
says at apple uh he says to his
employees get this
please
come back to the office oh yeah well
exactly that's different than ramsey oh
yeah we kind of just said come back to
the office voluntold i like that word
you know you were we've all told you
you're going to volunteer yourself back
to the office because this is where we
were right well so you know what that
speaks to two things number one tim cook
is weak
just being honest number one he runs the
largest company in the world yeah but
he's weak when he says that yeah but
he's afraid of his employees there's the
leverage issue yeah if those highly
skilled workers leave to go somewhere
else it's a lot harder to find them in
the sense of getting them in for the
same pace so he's trying to save money
by placating the workforce so i'm not
trying to take a shot at his character
i'm saying from a lot of [ __ ]
yeah well yeah
hello pot i'm kettle uh i mean he that's
a weak leadership move it really is you
can't plead and bargain with your
employees what you have to do is just
make it appealing for them to come in or
you put a clear directive out there says
if you don't come in you don't work here
and we've seen companies try that elon
musk did he said you know you can not
work from home correct
interesting times right now the the
chairs have shifted a good bit so very
it's a weird i think it may be the
weirdest job market i've seen in 30 or
40. that is correct the most unique very
very strange job market
vote for both sides the hiring and the
hired
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
author of the number one bestseller from
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five ruben is with us in corpus
christi texas hi reuben welcome to the
ramsay show
good thank you
what's up
hey um yeah me and my wife um had a
situation where
we have an opportunity to purchase a
house
and
right now we have about half of it or a
little more than half
but we can pay it in full if we clear
out her 401k so my question is should i
finance
that difference or should i just get out
of the 401k and just have a free and
clear house
sounds pretty tempting doesn't it
yes yeah
so if you take it out of the 401k you
get a 10 penalty plus your tax rate so
if your tax rate is 25 that's a 35 hit
on your money
so kind of what you just accidentally
asked me was dave i want to borrow money
at 35 interest
to have a paid for house
and that would that that would be of
course ridiculous wouldn't it okay okay
yeah uh and we said whatever you told us
i mean no no it's not what i yeah i want
you to think
you don't want to give up 35 of your
money right it's like 35 percent
interest
okay you understand
yes yes no i do okay i do so we just
borrow it from the bank yeah i assume
you're out of debt everything but the
hou but the house you're buying right
well yes yeah well we owe about six
thousand dollars on the truck and
thirty thousand on our car on her car so
other than that we don't have any
no full stop full stop full stop how
much money do you have in savings
um right now a hundred and eight
thousand dollars
okay and what's your household income
about 80 to
90 000 i guess
okay you're probably um not attuned
enough to the things that we talk about
here and we teach for you to actually do
this
but i'm going to go ahead and tell you
anyway what you should do and what i
would do if i woke up in your shoes i'm
guessing you're in your mid-20s
no i'm actually in uh we had a house
uh the house was almost paid off but we
had an accident well we didn't have an
accident on january the first a firework
got in my backyard while we were asleep
burned the whole house down we got out
alive thank god but
um
that happened and that's why we're in
this situation we're in uh we were
already paying off our house i mean
how old are you
i'm 47. oh okay all right all right
um well what we teach folks is your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income so getting out of debt and
staying out of debt
first step is everything but the house
then the house
um and when you make you said eighty
thousand dollars a year
between the yeah yeah well i would say
closer to 90 to 100 000 really i guess
well i mean what'd you pay taxes on dude
do you not know
um yes i paid on 55
she paid on i want to say 40 so
i i think that's about like 95. okay so
30 000 car does not fit in this equation
you have too much tied up in something
that's going down in value no it doesn't
fit at all i would sell it right
i guess i'd get a cheaper car and i
would pay them both off and with what's
left i would put it all down on the
house and i would put the house on a
15-year fixed rate or less and then i
would work on paying down the house
because you have no debt at that point
but
you shouldn't have more than half your
annual income and you potentially do are
very close to it tied up in things that
go down in value with wheels and motors
so the chances of you calling about a
401k withdrawal and me selling your 30
000 car in the same conversation are
fairly low i know that but it is still
what you should do
um and i hope i can convince you to
think about that anyway because if i
woke up in your shoes knowing what i
know now with all the stupid butt stuff
i have done in my life
uh i and if you were to talk to one of
the 10 000 millionaires that were in the
millionaire survey that we did for the
baby steps millionaire's book um
you would find that they would all say
the biggest mistakes they've ever made
are super expensive cars when they're
still broke and you are still broke
you're not broken like most people but
you don't have any money to mount
anything
um you're just still in your early
stages of wealth building and so you
need to get those cars cleared up the
best thing to do is i would rather you
be driving a 10 000 car and have another
20 on down on the house
then you keep this 20 30 car and pay
down on it personally if i was in your
shoes that's what i would do
and so i'd have a couple ten thousand
dollar cars i'd put as much down on this
house i could get it paid off and then
you're going to be in a position to
really super build wealth
but uh again i think i just sold mom's
car so i don't know if i'm gonna get
away with that or not yeah you three hit
a lot hit a lot there dave the 30 000
car
i got to sell that but it makes total
sense especially if uh if if you can
come out ahead on that and then put that
towards the other cars i think he said
six thousand in credit card debt as well
it was on the other car it was the other
car okay yeah so knocking that out is
gonna be huge
and here's the other thing uh you you
uh need to think about in this case
reuben is
car debt
is debt
you weren't sure of that early in the
conversation
so it's like oh we don't we're having
that but we got these two guard debts
thirty thousand and six thousand that's
debt it's a debt because if you don't
pay it they will repossess your butt and
then they will sue your butt
and that's what will happen and yeah so
it's debt it's going to has consequences
has problems heather's in roanoke
virginia hi heather how are you
doing great and it is such an honor to
speak with both of you all today you too
what's up my
my husband and i are in baby steps four
five and six my question has to do with
baby step four my husband's a pastor and
he's opted out of social security
so i was wondering do we need to be
investing more than the 15
since he will not be receiving social
security at all
no okay 15 is sufficient you'll be
very wealthy on 15 if that's all you
ever do but as you know 15 is not our
only plan it's 15 and two until you get
kids in college and you get the house
paid off when the house is paid off then
we max out everything and so how old are
you guys
um my husband is 50 and i am 49. do
either one of you have income that is
not pastoral income
yes i do okay obviously that has social
security coming out of it and if he does
anything other than pastoring that has
social security it's only his pastoral
income that's exempt
we have about in retirement um accounts
close to of course the market's been
down so at one point we're at about a
hundred thousand good for you good start
good start
so it's a good start okay i would opt
out i would do exactly what you've done
if i were in that situation i'm not
allowed to obviously
because i don't qualify i don't have
pastoral income that's that i can do a i
i can uh
object to i can't be a conscientious
objector to the social security system
uh legally i can morally and i am
morally i hate it uh but um but it is
there still and so um yeah if i were you
i would opt out and i would say 15 but
then you know finish the plan get out of
debt and house and everything and you
can and so ken we talked about this
before your dad's a pastor yeah opting
out um if folks that don't know that are
pastors you have the opportunity for
your pastoral income only not other
income if you're a pastor and you have
royalty from a book
that's taxable
you don't get out of it but your
pastoral income you can opt out as a
conscientious objector and you have to
sign a document with the irs that says
on a religious
basis i object to the social security
system and you have to be able to do
that with integrity now if i were in a
pastoral role i could do that with
integrity because
as a christian i'm real sure the bible
says to be a good steward a good manager
of god's resources and giving it to the
social security system by definition is
not a good use of god's money because it
sucks it has a negative rate of return
and it's a horribly run government
bloated
it's the dmv of retirement it's a mess
and so um
you know i can i can object to it on a
religious basis with good conscience if
i'm in that role if you can do that in
your pastor then you need to make sure
you have
life insurance in place
disability insurance in place and have a
retirement system a retirement plan in
place but you need those anyway pastor
regardless you gotta do that anyway
so while you're at it do good financial
planning don't count on the mother state
to take care of you this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we are
so glad you are with us open phones at
825-5225 this is the ramsey show we're
all about helping you
get to a different place a better place
in your career
a better place in your wealth building a
better place in your relationships this
is all about moving up a notch leveling
up as the important people say these
days open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five carl is next
in st louis hey carl what's up
hey how are you doing dave so glad to
talk to you uh really excited again here
with you okay um so
uh my wife and i have kind of been in
debt most of her life and um i wish i
found you 20 years ago and we paid off
so much of our debt uh we paid off my
car a little quicker and after that we
started putting that car payment towards
her car then we got sick and tired of
her car and started putting extra from
savings to it and we kept our savings at
a set level and put the extra against
that car and i was talking to my
financial advisor about a week ago and
she's like oh my gosh she's got one more
month of this just paid off you're gonna
feel so glad you did and so i did i paid
off the car and bought it i feel excited
so the only debt we have remaining is
our house
and uh we owe forty five thousand
dollars in the house
um we have thirty five thousand in
savings um
and uh my financial advisor is like oh
man you should just just put 25 of that
against your house you can pay that off
in four months then and just be done
with it and then build your savings back
up
and so i was kind of like you know
should i leave more in savings should i
just follow that just just take a big 25
000 chunk against savings knock the
house out quick
or should i just
keep paying on the house more and knock
it out in about nine months good for you
wow
well i like your financial advisor
i thought you might i mentioned your
name to her so much of the time
she hates debt she hates debt bad
and that's good because your
income once you get it all freed up is
she she knows the truth is going to
become your most
powerful wealth building tool
when you're not giving it all to someone
else as a way of life and you're
beginning to experience the emotions of
these numbers in the last few months it
sounds like and it's very exciting for
you i'm so proud of you yeah super
exciting okay so we teach a process very
that comes from the same principles that
she's leaning on that's why she and i
like each other i can tell
and um so baby step one is save a
thousand dollars you've done that
okay baby step two has become free
other than the home
and you've done that
baby step three
is have an emergency fund of three to
six months
of expenses
okay okay so i don't want your savings
below three months of household expenses
so if your household expenses are three
grand a month
then we can go with her plan
well without a house payment it would
definitely be you have a house right
here you have a house payment still yeah
yeah once that's knocked out
with house payment it's probably
okay with house payment monthly expenses
is probably
um well probably pretty close to three
okay well no that's not true i don't
think it's that much i'd say it's
probably i mean the house payments are
household incomes
um i make 145 my wife makes 48
right about 48. she's already there a
couple couple of hundred a year okay
and so um
uh
um
yeah
and if you take
you said there's 35 in there right in
your savings yes and 40 on the high or
40 or 45 on the house
35 in the house okay so if we throw 25
at it leave 10 in there like she
suggests
that means we have 20 left on a 200
dollar household income
and you're done by christmas then
yeah be done by christmas for sure yeah
okay
i don't want you below ten
uh because i i are you okay with him um
borderline but but
um
i just want you to gauge everything
around you and be very wary because if
you have a fifteen thousand dollar event
we got a problem dude you make 200 grand
and that's silly
yeah the other idea i had that i kind of
threw with my wife because um we were
putting it you know the first thing was
um take our house payment put our two
car payments against it and then put the
x we're putting from savings which takes
us to a house payment of 5100 a month
we're just going to keep cranking it up
and some other idea was every month you
know pay that and then pay an additional
five grand from savings and kind of see
how we feel as we're going with that
that would be okay too um
yeah i just don't want if i could
establish real comfortably what three
was i mean i'd be more comfortable with
15.
i'd probably do it if it was 15.
but okay people often call me and say i
have enough money in my savings account
to pay off my house today and it would
leave me with one thousand dollars left
in my account
and i would tell them no and i i'm the
get out of debt guy
and i'm still telling them no because i
don't want you sitting there with one
thousand dollars at this stage
of your financial plan
now at the beginning of your financial
plan when you're broke and got a bunch
of other debts and everything else
you're living on beans and rice but this
is more intentional than it is intensity
at your stage
and so i just want to be wise and
careful even though i'm as excited as
you are to get you out of debt so i'm
guessing that either way you're out of
debt by christmas
yeah it's going to be really close if
not i mean if we leave a little bit more
it's going to i think we're now i mean
another way you could another way you
could work
you know another you know we'll just
keep manipulating the numbers here but
if you said okay let's just call it
three to six months let's call it 20
grand throw
uh the rest of it at it and then just
start chunking on the house you're still
gonna make it and if you don't reach
over and pull 10 out and take it down to
10 for one month
yeah in december but just go
december i'm done
as long as i don't go below 10 in my
savings
but you could if the math works the math
works on throwing it at the debt or it
works and thrown into the account then
pulling out of the account
so either way is fine um
and uh but i would not stop are you
saving for 401k i would not stop that
absolutely yeah my wife puts about 11 in
i'm putting about seven percent in yeah
then i'm putting about another eight
percent into uh uh roth ira yeah yeah
you're getting you got the right numbers
and i wouldn't stop that either so
the the difference is only whether it's
uh christmas or whether it's march
that's the only difference and
and when you're 75 years old
that date won't matter i i like the
advice dave and i'd actually be a little
bit more cautious with that savings
because if if it's me and i really want
to get this because it's just intensity
he sees the finish line how could you
make five to ten grand extra that's what
i'm looking at i i like that savings
posture i really do having that just in
case a big event happens because you're
talking about the difference between
three months
so it's great advice i certainly agree
with you i wouldn't personally i started
getting a little nervous listening to
that going lower and 15 myself
10 or 15 has got to be your floor yeah
for sure but i mean you could just throw
money you know leave the savings like it
sits
and throw money at the house and then
when you get within striking distance of
taking it down to 15 then do it in one
lick yeah then you're sitting on savings
the whole time while you're waiting to
do it
and um that won't mess you up either
you'll still get there in exactly the
same period of time
exactly
and so yeah it's a great place to be
though carl i love where your head's at
and i i like that you found a financial
advisor who's understood that getting
out of debt is the key to building
wealth
because not having any payments you know
what you can do if you don't have any
payments anything you want
i mean it opens up the door baby it's
americans live in such bondage that we
don't even know what it's like to be
free yeah i was getting ready to say if
you're new to the show and you're
listening and watching carl is a great
example of where you can be you know he
started off by saying i wish i had found
you 20 years ago but they've jumped into
the process and now he's like at the
finish line he can't get there fast
enough it's a wonderful wonderful place
that's possible yeah it is amazing that
um that you can you know run for two
hours and a half marathon
and still have enough gas left to sprint
the last hundred yards once you see the
finish line that reminds me dave when i
was cramping up and had all kinds of
issues a couple years ago
and i was like a wounded wildebeest out
there and then i saw the finish line and
i just gutted it out it hurt so bad but
it was like oh
we were running beside you we were
cheering you on i don't know if what i
was doing could be described as running
while we were we were in motion going
forward
drag a leg all all in the name of the
coleman project oh there you go man
glad i retired that day
oh fun stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsey show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for being with us america ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two
five
up first this hour is going to be
theresa in san diego hi teresa welcome
to the ramsey show
yay hi dave hi ken hey what's up for all
you hi thank you for all you've done for
our family it's been you've been such a
blessing dave sure how can we help yay
okay so i have a husband who loves
business loves people and people love
him back he
he has a gift he's gifted in strategy
he's able to see big picture recognize
that's needed for people to be
successful
currently has a great job 15 years of
experience in the restaurant industry
but he's always expressed a desire to be
self-employed ultimately um
i need to know what i should do as his
partner to encourage him um to go out on
his own he really
if unleashed could just be such a
blessing to so many people
um so i don't know what that should look
like or how
or you know how where do we start um
does he have an actual idea or two or
three
uh ken it's
unbelievable like just living our daily
lives just going out and uh
going on vacations came back from
california uh visiting family within
that week's time he had three different
people um ask for him to look at their
numbers and actually be a board member
on some of these in the in these
businesses so it's it's like
does that answer your question no does
he have it no no you're right what kind
of business yeah like does he have an
actual idea or two that he's talked with
you about that he hasn't pulled the
trigger on a specific business idea
i would say consulting i mean
uh he loves business he loves helping
people succeed so right currently he's
in the restaurant industry
and is um loving it he loves has a
passion for industry but he has a
passion for people so sure
what did he say to the board offers did
he say yes or i'll get back to you or i
want to talk it over with the wife
well it's correct he would always talk
things over with me he's very wise
but uh yes but um
it's
that's why i'm kind of calling because
he he enjoys the job he has but it would
be
you know do i
okay so if if i were
yes he should he should absolutely
explore those board opportunities
specifically if they're paid
but even if they're not if it gets him
an opportunity to come in even as a
board member and begin to practice
advising outside of what he already
knows it's a wonderful way to get his
feet wet and kind of ease into what
could my future look like i would
absolutely explore this so i'd go home
and go hey uh when he comes home i said
i think you should explore these things
and look into these things
as an opportunity the second thing is is
i would ask him point blank just in your
normal conversation
uh what what would need to be true for
him to start his own consulting business
begin just having conversations with two
of you not high pressure i really want
you to do this but just begin to hear
his heart and he's going to begin to
share with you
uh what could hold him back or what is
holding him back and as he is oh good
tell me what is holding back
it's um financial stability so as i said
currently he has a great job um and
he doesn't know what that would look
like because his first and foremost
concern is to be a great provider for
sure so what if so here's what you say
to him what if you were to do this on
the side you can consult on the side and
he knows about how many hours or days
and based on his other responsibilities
kind of great he needs to do more of it
what do you mean kindness okay what's
kind of
um having conversations there he has
signed some nda so that's not consulting
he's having coffee
is he getting paid
no and that's why i'm asking like and
that's not because he has to get paid
and so here's here's how you help him
with this provider gap i'm going to tell
you first of all he he talks to these
people that want him as a board member
he finds out is it a paid board
opportunity i've got several friends who
are paid board members they show up a
couple meetings a year they're on call
and they make a nice decent chunk of
side money the other thing is is he may
not be a good board member but maybe
he's a consultant for them so if he's on
vacation and he's running into these
opportunities opportunity's not his
issue what he needs to understand is i
can walk before i run
and so we want to just start his
consulting business
today and he starts getting paid and
then he stacks that money up you
understand where i'm going with this he
keeps stacking the consulting money up
until he's got two things in play six
months would be my advice six months of
his current income in the bank of the
consulting business would be the start
and the second thing is a pipeline of
business
and then he's ready to walk yeah dave
you're gonna say something ken and i
have
more than two friends
that are mutual friends of ours
that make north of a half million
dollars a year
on retainer with businesses
a handful 50 business less than 50
businesses less than less than uh 20
businesses probably on on the list and
they're on an annual retainer plus
hourly
to uh help them with strategy to help
them with people problems to business
coach them
and they're they're great business minds
good guys they're hustle and they're
both making north of a half million
dollars a year so on a on a part-time
basis your husband could get enough of
that kind of thing going on
if he finally decided he was actually
going to get paid for instead of doing
that as a favor for everybody
that's yes that's for my frustration
that's what i was what my frustration
was that's why i said he's not going to
business coffee
buying coffee for people is not it
that's not the thing
so um
yeah and so if it's a paid board gig
that's advising and you can use that in
your resume to also land some of these
retainers but it's not unusual in that
business consulting space business
coaching space
for you to get an annual retainer and um
then you know and he doesn't want to
work with somebody that wants to give
him five grand one time
to fix one single problem because
business is never one problem right
that's a joke can i ask can i ask you
something else dave
some of these businesses that have come
up to him um are
like i said one of them offered the the
board membership you know and uh but
other ones are small businesses and i
know that you've talked about like when
you were starting out you would offer
equity um as an incentive to to help is
that
i think he feels uncomfortable i don't
want equity i want money
okay
okay
somebody's business
equity can come later let's get him to a
half million a year in cash
okay and then he's not got any barriers
right
he quits the restaurant that's how i
feel yeah the restaurant job goes away
instantly as soon as that is it becomes
a reality and by the way teresa if they
can't pay cash for his time they're not
the right client yeah and they're not
and they're in the early stages yes yeah
i mean some of these okay okay listen
we're not we're not that you can other
people can dream right now we want to do
business right okay i love it okay
yeah i can i don't know if you know this
or not but i have a rare position i get
paid to not be on people's boards that
is correct
that's where you all want to be by the
way that's where we're all trying to get
to
i serve on precisely zero boards
non-profit or otherwise and there is a
reason because you don't do well on
boards if you're always right that's
correct
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five he's been called
the best preacher in america he's been
called america's pastor he has sold more
than 145
million
products in print uh translation most of
those are books so this guy sold over a
hundred million
books
that's what everybody calls him uh i
call him friend pastor max lucado is
with us from san antonio texas with yet
another offering
pastor how are you sir
i'm great and i call you friend as well
my friend dave and it's just a treat to
talk to you well you too sir you too uh
things are going well i hope over there
get ready to see you guys in a few
months and
yes sir sir we're we're geared up we're
looking for it i think it's uh early
november you'll be speaking at our
church we're already excited yeah we're
excited excited to be there it's a
honor to have that opportunity so the
new book is help is here finding fresh
strength and purpose
in the power
of the holy spirit now you've written on
a lot of different things
uh why help is here at this time
well i believe that uh our society is
just worn out
a lot of it we brought on ourselves some
of it has
been sent our way but look around us
everybody is so weary
and i do not believe we're made to to
live that way and i believe we need much
more
than
just government programs for more
education or more
neighborly suggestions and i do i
believe what we need is supernatural
help and that power comes from the holy
spirit and so i'm i'm on a crusade to
urge people to tap into the only power
in the universe and that's the power of
the holy spirit you know the uh
weariness um
we're seeing that in a bunch of the
metrics that we follow here in the money
space the mental wellness space the
career space
weary weary is a good word fatigued is a
good work and part of it is being angry
is exhausting
it is
and people are people are spending an
inordinate amount of their lives angry
these days are you seeing that
no doubt and we we are expecting things
out of one another that one another
simply cannot provide and um
you know it the promise of jesus before
he ascended into heaven was
to his disciples so you shall receive
power when the holy spirit has come upon
you and i believe that power is
power to make good choices power to get
out of bed power to go to work power to
pay your bills you know just power
strength and and i think we're turning
to the wrong places uh and finding the
wrong results and so i'm excited to
get the conversation about the holy
spirit into our our national uh
conversation well i want to follow up on
that max because one of the chapters in
this book is how to hear from god
and i think that is probably one of the
most uh
powerful questions a perk a person can
ask if they've got a lot of people
listening watching today that may not
even believe you can hear from god what
would you say to someone who's wrestling
with that
all-important question
well the bible says that that
god has a will for us that is good and
pleasing
and perfect that's in a scripture called
romans 12 and verse 2. he has a a will
for us a plan for us that is good and
pleasing
and perfect and he doesn't keep that
will a secret
uh he reveals it to us all along he has
been not just the god who feeds us but
the god who leads us he guides us
and it is the assignment of the holy
spirit on the earth right now
to direct us and i believe that when a
person says yes to jesus
then god says yes to them
and places within them the essence of
himself the invisible yet undeniable
presence
of the holy spirit and he speaks to us
through two ways can through the verse
and the voice
the verse is scripture the bible which
is inspired by god and then the voice
and the voice is that that leading that
prompting that
nudging that sense of right and wrong
that we have and even increasingly have
more the longer we uh live with the
spirit and follow him so the verse and
the voice the holy spirit uses both of
those to lead us
a pastor friend of mine says uh don't
don't say you went with your
my gut he goes don't call the holy
spirit a gut
i like that i like that so you talk
about i like the idea of following our
conscience you know i want to follow
god's conscience uh and that's what he
places within us
yeah absolutely
the calming presence of god is how you
talk about the holy spirit um i i've
often heard someone say when they're
looking for that leading that ken was
talking about in that chapter of yours
that that uh the peace of god over a
decision is an indication you're on the
right feet in the right area if you've
got a bunch of angst about it it's
probably not god right right and and
because one of the attributes of the
holy spirit is peace the very first
mention of the holy spirit in the bible
is in genesis chapter 1 and verse 2
where the spirit of god hovered over the
deep you know before creation became the
beautiful creation we enjoy it was it
was angry and tumultuous but the holy
spirit came and hovered over it maybe
like an eagle would hover over a flock
of newborns in a nest to calm them down
and when when jesus was baptized the
holy spirit came in the form of a dove i
can't imagine a bird more calming more
presence more reassuring uh than than a
dove and so the holy spirit brings peace
he calms us down so if you're anxious
today
all you need to do is is offer a simple
prayer and say i received the holy
spirit please speak words of calm over
the chaos of my life
and uh i think you'll be surprised at
the at the supernatural
sense of peace that comes over your life
uh max is joining us here on the ramsey
show the new book is help is here max
when you write about anything i know
that that that inevitably god works
through what you're writing in your own
life curious uh what experience did you
have during writing this book
well um you know throughout my
my ministry i'm 67 now so i'm getting
kind of old aren't i uh early on in my
ministry i i almost quit because it was
i found being a pastor so stressful
and the holy spirit came
to me one night in prayer time and
comforted me and i sensed a message from
him
just to be to be quiet and to be still
and to trust
and that has continued all these many
years and as i was writing this book i i
really sensed you know the holy spirit
gives gifts
uh their their their abilities to to
teach or heal or to bless or encourage
and the scripture says to earnestly seek
the gifts of the spirit so i i began
praying i said lord are there any gifts
that you've not given me that i need to
have to finish my life in good in good
fashion and
lo and behold a couple of abilities came
my way that that i had not enjoyed so
far so i think god is ultimately a gift
giver and the holy spirit comes with
gifts and nobody is excluded any person
any person who says yes to christ can
receive abundant gifts of the holy
spirit
that's good news you always come bearing
good news and that's one of the reasons
we love hanging out with you so uh well
appreciate it thank you you and i are
overdue to hang out a little bit and uh
you know i brag on you everywhere i go i
tell stories of all the people in our
church
who's uh have been well they've they've
come in contact with financial peace
university or ramsey solutions and story
after story after story that's why we're
excited that you'll be coming to speak
to our people and we're honored too
pastor max lucado america's pastor the
new book is help is here finding fresh
strength and purpose in the power of the
holy spirit uh if you're weary
pastor has found uh found your recipe
you ought to try it it's good stuff
thanks for being with us max
thank you sir all the best
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five 825-5225
chris and amber are with us in hartford
connecticut it says on my screen you
guys are debt free congratulations
oh thank you thank you well done how
much did you pay off
uh just over 97 000. very good and how
long did that take
about 29 months good for you and your
range of income during that time
uh started at 88 000
and went to uh 120. cool what kind of
debt was the 97 000
most of it student loans
about 80 000 of it was student loans and
then we were pretty normal a car loan
some taxes some medical debt and a
little bit on credit cards
cool
okay so what happened 29 months ago put
you on this
ramsey way of doing things
yeah so uh when we first got married um
we had taken financial peace and really
work the steps a little bit but we're
davish as everyone says
um and a couple years ago we really
calculated
everything with a student loan all
together totaled it up and it was pretty
gut wrenching
and that was just an eye uh eye opening
thing to really just get on the same
page and whatever we had to do we were
going to get rid of this and change our
our story
okay so i helped me with this because
i'm always curious about
the the tipping point on this whole
process from a behavior standpoint you
go through the class
and that doesn't do it
and you come along how long later a
couple of years later
yeah so i think i think what was the
thing that pushed it back to the front
in your mind a couple years later
yeah i think um
we really
we really originally didn't um
have too much that we were worried about
because in in my mind at least
you know student loan was something i
was always going to be paying off and we
were younger and just
we knew the principles but for whatever
reason didn't act on that maybe shied
away from it and
when we finally i guess i can say when i
finally manned up and really just took
it for what it was and really looked at
what my family was in
i was done and i was going to do
everything i could to get rid of it
so there was no single thing
it just kind of creeped back to the
forefront in your mind
well i think our daughter being born in
about a year okay there we go
that's logical that makes more sense
okay then just generally wandered up
into your face yeah okay yeah baby
coming just got real yeah this is like
now this is real adult stuff we got to
well we got a real real your why changed
great okay okay that makes sense thank
you i was trying to get my head around
it wasn't it wasn't that the other was
troubling i just didn't understand it so
it's like it went from helpful
information to oh this is very useful
now that i have another human being to
perform yeah i have to be like a
grown-up now because now we have a real
child here yeah that that does it
doesn't it
yes it does yeah having a baby's a big
time thing that's wonderful how's your
baby then now two and a half years i
guess
no so she was she was um she was born
about a year before that so okay so
you're looking at this little
one-year-old toddling around yeah yeah
and you're going oh
baby yeah
okay all right that makes sense very
cool okay so then you drag the fpu
materials back out and go through them
again huh
exactly yeah and in fact um it was
helpful for me um you know listening to
the podcast and doing different things
but i was able to to teach fpu a couple
times during it which was a learning
curve for me because the more i got into
it to help others the more i learned and
we could apply for our family so it was
it was the more the more i ate the more
i wanted to do it yeah i hear you well
the more you teaching a class
you have to do it because otherwise
you're a hypocrite right yeah it's like
it's doubled it's a double-edged sword
then yeah yeah so amber i'm just curious
once you both got fully on board here
was there a real uh tough moment or
maybe a season of learning how to do
this or was it pretty lickety-split for
you guys
um no i think there was definitely a
learning curve for us um
uh following a budget um i my profession
is social work i i'd done case
management for 13 years and so i was out
on the road a lot so i think for me
learning not to make my coffee at home
and not go out and get coffee what you
know those sorts of things were kind of
the learning curve what can we do to
save money because you don't realize how
much you're spending until you actually
look at the numbers there
yeah changes everything wow
very cool good for you guys okay now
you've done it 97 000 paid off in 29
months you're professionals you've
taught the class twice someone says how
do you get out of debt what do you tell
them the keys are
well i would say there's a lot um but i
i think communication with your spouse
or or an accountability partner
was huge we had to get on the same page
you were very different around you know
different things and so using the every
dollar app was something that
was able to get us on the same page
i think
you know and we've said it many times
you keep going no matter what no matter
what has to keep going on there's no
stopping you know and we learn that the
wrong way you know in the first time
and then the budget is vital even when
it looks overwhelming like it did for us
that's that's that's your key you gotta
keep to it and tell that money where to
go
so ninety seven thousand and twenty nine
months
did it go faster or slower than it felt
like it was going to when you started
huh
i think faster i think as we got
momentum
um it seemed to creep a little bit at
the beginning but yeah as you got more
momentum and with the student loan
stopping interest and things like that
we just applied everything we could
to that and that was our opportunity to
really get get ahead
will you ever go back in debt
of course not
good
good lord he said i can't imagine
working this hard
[Laughter]
i love it
very fun very fun well i'm proud for you
guys your heroes well done we're proud
of you
very well done and thank you for leading
a financial peace class we appreciate
that from you you guys are incredible
very cool how old are you two
so i am 39 and she's 38. okay
so not even 40 and you got rid of
navient
man that's a good person to get out of
your basement for sure well we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
how ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too my latest number
one best seller and a a financial peace
university membership for a year you'll
be able to give that to someone as
you're leading classes and gift it to
somebody who needs to be in the class
and you can help them get started add a
total money makeover book for the same
thing to give somebody a leg up and get
them started lots of gifts for you to
re-gift and uh thank you guys so much
we're so proud of you heroes way to go
thank you appreciate it chris and amber
hartford connecticut 97 000 paid off in
29 months making 88 to 120 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
that's how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
yeah
love it love it love it
very very well done
fabulous
hey guys we are doing the building
wealth live events in your city
and they're almost all completely sold
out we will be in phoenix uh com this
coming monday the 12th and it is sold
out we will be in phoenix on tuesday and
it is sold out we will be in sacramento
november the 1st and it is sold out
these are 3 to 5 000
person venues
we will be in minneapolis november the
10th it is the only one that has a few
tickets left there's less than 100
tickets available for that so if you
want to come out minneapolis you're
almost sold out there san antonio
november the 15th sold out so we will be
there ken coleman dr john deloney me
rachel cruz george camel it's going to
be a lot of fun ken it really is you
know we we had a wonderful spring season
and you know it's it's fun to see in all
of the so-called political and
societal and economic tumult we we see a
great group of people there for one
reason they really are serious about
building wealth creating a new family
tree and it's electric it's a lot of fun
dr john and i do a special session
pre-event uh that you may be able to get
tickets for that dave i don't know but
that's a lot of fun a fun conversation
about anxiety and work and at home and
how to win in both areas check it out
pastor start at 25 you can get a four
pack uh minneapolis for as low as 60
dollars go to
ramseysolutions.com
events
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day first
corinthians 15 58 be steadfast immovable
always abounding in the work of the lord
thomas jefferson said on matters of
style swim with the current on matters
of principle
stand like a rock
i always get tickled when i see that
i've i probably saw that quote 20 years
ago the first time and you think of
thomas jefferson's styling right
well you know he was he was
he was quite the goat man yeah you know
it's one of my all-time favorites i love
that quote it's so powerful but yeah he
was a you know he spent a lot of time in
france and paris as an ambassador and
really was quite the stylist guy and
brought a lot back to his home in
monticello so i get it even though it is
weird to think of style back then but
you know it's fun oh matters of style
swim with the current yeah just roll
with it oh matter's a principal stand
like a rock there you go
gotta love it gotta love it founding
fathers open phones at eight eight two
five
five two two five jason's in kansas city
hi jason how are you
hey i'm great how are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
i figured hey thanks for taking my call
i have a quick question on a rental and
putting down payment on a rental so my
wife and i are debt free we currently
contribute uh we max our 401k and we
currently contribute to our child's for
um to the child's college fund and we
are excited to buy a second home to use
as a short-term rental and you're
wondering what your current home is paid
for as well
it is not that is the only debt we've
got is our mortgage other than that we
are debt-free okay
so we are wanting to know we want to put
20 percent down it could be about a
million dollars um we're currently saved
up at about 150 000
so we're 50 short and i'm trying to
fast-track that so i wanted to know does
it make sense to um stop temporarily
stop contributing to the child's college
and 401k we could pay it off i'm sorry
save about fifty thousand dollars in
about a year um you got the [ __ ] bad
short term you got the fever bad for
this it's a good time to buy in a year
dave
you got the fever bad was a beach house
or what
mountain house mountain house good old
cabin yeah i figured yeah
well i don't know if you're gonna do
what we teach or not
because you got the fever
but i'll tell you what i have done and
what we have recommended since i've been
on the air
that when you do a second house
even if it's for income rental property
or partial
vacation home you know resort rentals
what you're dealing with here
that you pay cash for it after your home
is paid for
i have a lake house
and the first purchase i ever made like
that was a lake house um and um
it's not the one i'm currently in but um
it was uh
it was a big deal to us our home was
paid for we saved up the money we paid
cash for the little it wasn't a very
fancy place but it got us on the water
and we got it you know we had a place to
go on the weekends the kids grew up
skiing down there and then later on we
tore that house down and got rid of the
house gate donated it and moved it and
built another bigger property on that
same lot and that's where we were last
weekend um but you know luxury
properties if you even if you partially
justify them with
um
rental income with resort rental income
which is heavy in management fees uh
because it's generally nightly rentals
um and it's generally seasonal too
uh but the uh even if you partially
justify it with that uh is still at the
end of the day a toy
and you pay cash for toys now again i
don't know if i'm gonna talk you out of
this you sound to me like the words
you're using your sentence structure
you're pretty far down the road on this
but i would pay off your home first
and then i would save up and buy my
rental properties or save up and buy my
uh
second homes with cash and by the way
that's what i have done
uh i didn't do otherwise and i didn't do
a different thing and then teach you
guys different because i'm gonna get you
out of debt and keep you out of debt
um and so of all the millionaires that
we interviewed
ten thousand of them jason
uh we didn't have one that said you know
i made all my money leveraging into my
vacation mountain house
after i'd gotten out of debt and almost
got my house paid off i leveraged into a
vacation mountain house and that that
made all the difference in my
finances on the contrary we asked them
what mistakes they have made and almost
always it was associated with going into
debt to buy a car or to buy something
after they had almost made it and you've
almost made it so i really would ask you
to rethink this
but i'll say one more time from the way
you're talking about this i don't know
if we did any good or not
it's hard it's hard to back out once
you're that far in yeah i was going to
ask you a follow-up on that what was he
really i mean how would someone you've
explained all of the financial piece
what would you coach him with
emotionally if he's going to actually do
what you told him how do you get to that
place when you're already you can see it
taste it smell it
cold shower
i was waiting for there it is folks
that's good it's only going to break the
fever
take two of these and call me in the
house it's house fever right it's just
because i do the same thing i get when i
am purchasing
even to this day um when the vast
majority of my purchases today are not
they don't move the needle right but uh
in terms of the emotions of it um but
even that like i get ready to buy a car
i get into it sure and i'm studying it
and you know the the you know the
activator thing you start seeing them
everywhere right oh yeah and uh i get
into it and you just we all do that yeah
we all get and the bigger the purchase
the more complicated the purchase the
bigger the purchase relative to your
situation oh yeah the more
you the the more you obsess about it
yeah and this in this situation is a
true lifestyle purchase like he can see
a million dollars that is right second
home oh yeah almost totally on that
right
i mean
20 down's a joke on that i mean it's
just not even right
it's hard to get the financing at that
but the uh
still it's just
uh
that's a lot yeah but i mean he's he's
he's he's spent a lot of nights in that
cabin in his mind already that's what
i'm saying i would have it was me yes
sir i get i get all jacked up about it
he's already found a breakfast place at
the bottom of the hill everything
listen i bought a new surf boat a new
master craft surf boat oh
i got so much dialed into that man i was
so
every detail on the website every color
choice every little d new i mean you
would have thought i was doing a 8
million dollar transaction right right
i'm just so dadgum down and stuck my
head so far in it and if you just told
me in the middle of that if my wife had
said you know i changed my mind i don't
think we should do that
because you get you get into it and
that's just a normal human process so i
don't know if i know how to tell you how
to back out of it other than joke about
it and just go it's human nature and uh
sometimes you need to put full stop on a
bad idea yeah um when you're in the
middle of it and i will tell you this um
you know we have pastor max on yeah and
he's talking about peace
the peace of the holy spirit
and um
there's a scripture that goes with that
from a financial standpoint
that says the blessings of the lord
have no sorrow added to them
and so if i can look at the situation
and can perceive
sorrow
in the future of it
then that usually is telling me that's
not a god thing i'm doing it's a dave
thing i'm doing
and i got that
i done went and got the fever you know
that was it i i mean i i got the fever
yeah yeah you know
about it i got i got suckered in by my
own intellect and i can i can i can do
mental gymnastics and talk myself into
something and all you out there can too
sure we all can we all do it and so it's
a it's an interesting call to not poke
fun at jason just to instead say we're
all just like you yes for sure and yet
begging you not to do this deal
because it's not good for your family so
it's really what could go wrong because
oh so much and then you start to deal
with that and that kind of becomes that
cold shower hopefully to go all right
wait a second the most high risk real
estate is being a developer
developing a property
in the slots or whatever you're doing
with it the second most high risk real
estate resort real estate right
and because if you think about it resort
real estate is luxury and so what
happens is beach and mountain lake
they all go straight up when times are
hot
and straight to the bottom when times
are cold because it's the first thing
that people
dump
when they're when they're struggling
that's right and and and they buy it
when they're flush
and so when the economy's going to zoom
zoom you know my lake house will i'll
double some years and it'll go in half
later on you know in value as we watch
it back and forth and that happens with
beach property it happens with you know
you watch the 30a coast down there oh
been going zoom zoom for a while but i
do remember when there were towers
sitting empty with wind blowing through
them down there they have to stink in
places on foreclosure and it doesn't
feel like that long ago to me
so you know it's just
it's it's very volatile category of real
estate
ken coleman good job james and kelly
andrew zach ben and austin in the booth
i am dave ramsey your host we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus dave here we just
launched a brand new audience survey for
the ramsey show and we'd love your
feedback you could be entered to win a
500 visa gift card no purchase necessary
take the survey at ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]